the scenes out of afghanistan have been
heartbreaking desperate people doing
whatever they can to flee the country as
the taliban re-establishes control over
the capital city and the rest of the
country
some people are calling it a catastrophe
other people are calling it a nightmare
and msnbc reporters are calling it
a relatively peaceful takeover
the country is essentially now in the
hands of the taliban for all intents and
purposes uh they've taken over kabul the
president or should i now say the former
president of afghanistan ashraf ghani
has fled the country the taliban have
taken over the presidential palace
they've renamed the country the islamic
emirate taken down the afghan flag and
hoisted up
their own colors and it's been a
relatively
peaceful if you like a process they
haven't had to fire a lot of shots there
hasn't been a lot of bloodshed in kabul
it was a pretty straightforward takeover
for them uh they've also taken over the
airport they've been reports of shots
fired at the airport and taliban
fighters are are all over the place
uh but they're not in any sort of
clashes with u.s personnel although
commercial flights have so far been
suspended
that's a lot of whiplash it's it's a
mostly peaceful takeover of the country
and it's peaceful and there are
definitely shots being fired by the
militants who are ever but it's mostly
peaceful turns out that relatively
peaceful takeovers much like mostly
peaceful protests seem to involve a fair
bit of violence but joe biden has
doubled down on the strategy in his
first comments since everything that he
said wouldn't happen happened in
afghanistan
with the president this week is it any
wonder that democrats want to ban donald
trump from ever appearing on a ballot
again msnbc
sees the glass half full so that's the
same network by the way that called the
george floyd riots mostly peaceful
protests with the the buildings burning
down behind them now they're saying this
is a relatively peaceful takeover i
suppose as far as takeovers go it
actually is
relatively peaceful meaning yeah they're
executing lots of people and beheading
lots of people but there's no major
battle taking place in kabul because the
afghan military didn't even fight back
and the american
forces were were leaving the political
leadership said pull out of the country
the state department taking a similarly
optimistic view so the the state
department spokesman ned
price
is is confident
uh in the ability of the united states
to impel the taliban
to have an inclusive government
additionally the u.n security council
issued a joint press statement earlier
today calling for a new government that
is united
inclusive
and representative including with the
full and
full and meaningful participation of
women
the council spoke with one voice to
underscore that afghanistan must abide
by its international obligations
including to international humanitarian
law and ensure the safety and security
of all afghans and international
citizens
i'm sure that'll do it uh it's done it's
over i don't know why we spent 20 years
in a military occupation of afghanistan
when ned price could have just gotten on
tv
or and frankly he might still do this
written a strongly worded letter to the
taliban and said hey
dear taliban
to whom it may concern at the taliban
we want you to elect women to your
government and if you don't well we're
we in the international community will
be very disappointed in you taliban okay
so maybe think about that
taliban as far as i can tell
completely ignoring the the demands of
the united states state department uh
one cnn reporter observing on the ground
a cnn reporter who is now wearing a
hijab because otherwise she'll be killed
she's now wearing hijab but she's
looking on the bright side she's saying
sure you know these guys seem pretty
they're saying mean things they don't
sound like they're going along with this
but
they seem friendly enough
they're just chanting death to america
but they seem friendly at the same time
it's utterly bizarre
they're look they're mostly friendly
terrorists who want to destroy our
country mostly friendly though and
actually i hate to give credit to cnn
too but
in a way they do seem kind of friendly
in a way that's the scariest part
because if you look at the clip their
children say oh that's to america
we took over the country
hey buddy buddy habibi that's to america
oh gosh
it's bad it's bad it's not looking good
seems like a contradiction but there it
is chanting death to america
but but mostly friendly
a takeover of a country but mostly
peaceful
i'm glad you liked that clip i would
strongly encourage you go subscribe to
the michael knowles show podcast on
apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher wherever you get your podcast
just go just head on over there right
now and click subscribe
then leave a five star review appreciate
that and then you can get this full
episode which is about the friendly
peaceful taliban takeover we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]